I have a bunch of patients who are
waiting for it right they've been
approved they've not been approved
they're waiting and hoping to be
approved these two doctors have
conflicting viewpoints on euthanasia in
their country I think Canada's approach
to assisted dying has been successful I
am very concerned about medical
assistance and dying laws in Canada
euthanasia became legal in Canada in
2016. they call it medical assistance in
dying or made for short since then the
number of assisted deaths in Canada has
risen to over 10 000 people in 2021
that's more people by raw number than
any other country where assisted dying
is legal
in 2021 eligibility for made expanded to
include people who were not nearing the
end of their lives and starting next
year that will include people suffering
solely from serious mental conditions
too our participants are here to engage
any new kind of debate yeah that's where
you and I would disagree I know where
instead of fighting over unvetted
talking points we ask each expert to
pick three facts that their opponent
would have to concede are true Dr Maher
do you agree that these facts are true I
do Dr Green do you agree that these
facts are true yes I do they'll present
their facts and they'll each get a
chance to respond with a footnote
and after the fact exchange we'll also
have four additional rounds to further
clarify their positions
this is a fact check debate about
euthanasia and Canada
here we go
thank you
in Canada assisted dying is a
rights-based issue resulting from
constitutional Court challenges the
legalization of assisted dying did not
come about due to voter initiated
ballots has happened in some U.S states
or because the government thought it was
a good idea both of which can change
with shifting political wins importantly
these court cases were brought and won
by people with both terminal and
non-terminal illnesses
it is true that court cases gave people
who didn't have terminal illness
the right to have assisted deaths but
one of the plaintiffs in that key case
Jean truchel who had cerebral palsy when
he was considering getting assisted
death what he said was that it was the
loneliness that was brought on them by
the pandemic that was leading him to
make that choice so I'm really concerned
about what that means for people in
Canada who will make choices to die not
for medical reasons alone or maybe not
even primarily because of medical
reasons but because of social reasons
poverty isolation loneliness that
worries me a great deal
ultimately LED his challenge to the new
law for assisted dying because he was
about to lose function in his remaining
limb that was his initial incentive
ultimately this comes down to a question
of Rights and who if anyone controls Our
Lives
my name is Dr Stephanie Green and I'm a
provider of assisted dine in British
Columbia Canada I've always been taught
about the importance of patient-centered
care and I have found it to be
profoundly meaningful to be involved at
this time in their life and to provide
and facilitate their final wishes
there are 15 countries that allow some
form of medically assisted dying
including 10 U.S states in Washington DC
that allow people with a six-month
prognosis to self-administer a
prescribed drug Canada is one of eight
countries that allows assisted dying for
people without a terminal diagnosis next
year it will join most of these
countries in extending eligibility to
people whose only condition is a mental
illness
in these countries cases involving
primarily psychiatric conditions are
rare in Belgium and the Netherlands they
made up about one percent of all cases
Canada's assisted dying laws lack the
safeguards that other countries have
there is no requirement that all
reasonable treatments at least have been
tried by the patient the doctors are
able to initiate the conversation there
is no review process there's nobody
looking to see whether people in Canada
license to do this have in fact followed
the law and followed the rules
Canada rejected paternalism in medicine
quite a few decades ago the Supreme
Court decision states that a patient is
not required to undertake Medical
Treatments that are unacceptable to the
individual we have long accepted that
patients can refuse medical treatment
even if the results of that refusal is
death there's actually a very rigorous
process in place for this assisted dying
model there's a number of Eligibility
criteria but once they're met there are
on top of that a number of procedural
safeguards
of course we're in complete agreement
that paternalism is not a good thing and
every Canadian is free to make their own
choices but when we're talking about
assisted death we're talking about
choices made at a point in time when a
person is profoundly vulnerable my name
is John Maher I'm a psychiatrist with a
community mental health Team in Ontario
Canada
my goal is to help my patients live
their lives the way they want and to do
all we can to ensure that mental illness
and all that follows from that doesn't
keep them from living full Rich lives
an initial concern that people would
request assisted dying because they
couldn't access palliative care
foreign
has put that fear to rest
over 80 percent of the people who
receive made in Canada are receiving
palliative or Hospice Care at the time
of their death for those few who are not
88 of them have access to such care
compare that to The Wider Canadian
population and all causes of death when
statistics suggest that only a minority
people are receiving palliative care
before they die
the data that you're referencing
comes from the forms that are filled out
by the made providers and it tells us
nothing nothing at all about the quality
of the palliative care we also know from
the data you're citing that 21 of people
who who received made had palliative
care for less than two weeks while it's
true we don't have an objective marker
for the quality of palliative care
received what we do know from lots of
data is that since made was legalized in
Canada we have a significant increase in
the funding for research for palliative
care and an increase in the number of
people receiving and dying with
palliative care at home the vast
majority of people who access made in
Canada are patients with a cancer
diagnosis the next most common
underlying illness or end-stage organ
failures so end-stage heart disease
end-stage lung disease and staged liver
disease and neurologic conditions
they're around that 10 to 15 percent
range
the wait times for made in Canada are
shorter than the wait times to get a lot
of specialized services that might be
pain clinics psychiatric care Long-Term
Care Homes veterans benefits Supportive
Housing community-based care
that's not right
my job as a maid provider requires Me by
law to ensure that my patients have been
offered the resources and services that
could potentially reduce their suffering
I agree we need to reduce wait times but
at some point when potentially helpful
resources are not reasonably available
we can no longer hold individuals
Hostage to society's failings it seems
to me that the greatest failing we're
talking about here is a society that's
willing to help its citizens die rather
than provide the services that we know
help that we know work that we know
reduce suffering killing people while
they're on wait lists
is profoundly immoral
foreign
National polls consistently show that
the Canadian public supports assisted
dying this includes people who
self-identify as religious and people
with disabilities these polls were
conducted before our law changed to
allow assisted dying in the first five
years of legalized practice and in every
year since the amendment that extended
eligibility outside the end of life
context two polls that ask Canadians
about their views on made for mental
illness came back with very different
results one poll showed over 60 percent
of Canadians in favor another poll one
in particular looking at made for mental
illness showed that only 31 percent of
Canadians support it I don't think
Canadians have a full understanding of
what is happening but those
organizations that are focused on what's
Happening and drawing attention to it
namely the 137 disability organizations
in Canada the national indigenous
organizations the mental health
organizations the United Nations
everyone who is looking at this and
understanding what is going on is
Gravely concerned about the
discriminatory impact of this
legislation
Canadians have been talking about and
debating assisted dying since the 90s
there are multiple reports multiple
committees multiple news stories
multiple court cases to suggest that
Canadians are unaware of what the issue
is is not exactly fair to the Canadian
public
there is no consensus among Canadian
psychiatrists on when any particular
psychiatric illness is incurable and
under the law that comes into effect in
2024 in Canada a psychiatric illness
must be incurable and a person must be
in a state of irreversible decline but
we can't say who that is
consensus in health care is rarely
required there's no consensus amongst
doctors about whether they can
accurately predict a prognosis of six
months yet it's an eligibility
requirement for assisted dying in
several countries including the United
States however in Canada for me to
proceed two independent clinicians must
be of the opinion that the patient's
condition is incurable when someone has
a terminal illness
say cancer we have a pretty good idea
of how long they might live might not be
precise but we have a good idea in
mental illness we have no idea people
get better after five years after 10
years these are very very different
conditions very different circumstances
how we'll move on to the addition
Al experiences
certainties
[Music]
Stephanie could you ask John a question
that helps clarify his position
John do you believe every person with a
mental health disorder can be treated
successfully because if not and they
have capacity should they not be allowed
to access the same legal Health Care
available to everyone else
we both know the majority of people
living with mental illness have full
capacity they can make their own
treatment decisions to answer your
question can we treat everyone
I don't think that's the right question
the question is can we reduce suffering
can we help people cope with suffering
there are certainly going to be people
whose illness will not get better their
physical illness but can we mitigate
their experience of their symptoms can
we bring
support care compassion love to them in
a way that makes their life for them
worthwhile I'm not talking about denying
anyone the option of choosing made to be
frank everyone can already
choose suicide what we're working to do
is to ensure that every person is
treated with respect dignity provided
with care and support that we know can
help reduce suffering
do you like to ask Stephanie
only one in three Canadians have access
to mental health care who need it only
one in five children we know from
disability organizations across the
country that disability supports are
completely inadequate to live a
meaningful life people are are suffering
in ways that we can do something about
I'm asking you
would you support providing made to
someone while they're waiting
for treatment or care that could help
them
but it's down the road a bit
I would happily stand with you and call
for our government to do better than
what it's doing I think it's a separate
issue there can come a time
on a case-by-case basis every situation
is individual every situation is unique
and every case needs to be assessed in a
unique way there may be a time when a
certain treatment is available too far
away much too expensive inaccessible to
the patient in this case we have to
seriously consider not holding them
hostage to societies failing and to
consider offering made if it's truly
what they need
tough situation
I grant you that
John can you tell us something from your
personal experience that has
strengthened your conviction on this
issue
as a psychiatrist who works with
Community Mental Health Team
supporting people with the most serious
mental illnesses We are Becoming
overwhelmed by what made as introduced
into our clinical worlds I have patients
who are already saying I'm going to stop
treatment I'm not going to keep trying
I can die our efforts to help them stick
with the very challenging and sometimes
long-term treatment required to heal and
recover is being undermined we're not
just doing suicide prevention anymore
we're doing maid prevention
I'm going to tell you about a gentleman
I'll call Ray who was 62 years old with
metastatic lung cancer and Ray had been
asking for maid for quite some time
and as he and I worked through the
rigorous eligibility criteria
at some point I was able to sit in front
of him and tell him
he was eligible for this care and when I
sat there and did that I saw in him
a physical transformation is which I've
learned actually happens almost every
time
I saw his shoulders relax I think I saw
him smile for the first time since I'd
met him and it was immediately followed
by an expression of gratitude for the
mere possibility he decided to proceed
with maid and we held it not long after
in the rooftop garden of the facility in
which he was living and as is required
by law I was seeking his final consent
before I administered the medication he
was surrounded by his friends
and as he gave me that consent he
reached out and grabbed my hand he
looked at me and he said I know this is
going to sound odd Dr Greene but I think
you saved my life and it reminds me all
the time that for the people who
actually need and want this care it is
tremendously important
Stephanie what is one piece of specific
misinformation that you've heard about
made that you'd like to correct recently
a number of eye-catching headlines have
appeared in the news about Canadians
requesting assisted dying due to the
threat of homelessness or the fact that
they're living in poverty and while it's
true that anyone can ask for an
assessment of eligibility for maid and
those unacceptable social inequities
might be contributing towards suffering
the law is actually perfectly clear and
Canadians cannot access made based on
those factors alone
John would you like to clarify a piece
of misinformation some made providers
have argued that made
for non-terminal conditions
is not suicide
for decades suicide has been defined as
taking steps to arrange your own death
some have said that what makes made
different than suicide is that it's well
thought out it's not impulsive
but in fact in one U.S survey of over
1.4 million Americans 80 percent of
people reported that they thoughtfully
planned their suicide which means that
we have to consider where it fits into
all of our Suicide Prevention efforts
and whether it undermines those very
directly
foreign
called uncertainties
John what is something we don't know
about this issue that we need more
research on
Canada currently collects data
on the illnesses the physical illnesses
that lead to requests for made what we
don't have is data that considers the
socioeconomic reasons people might
request it and how significant an impact
that might have on the request and
perhaps whether it drives it completely
we don't know whether poverty
homelessness being on a wait list for
treatment being refused disability
benefits we don't know why people are
choosing made and we should on this
point John I think we're almost in
agreement Canada has recently expanded
the type of data it's gathering on
patients who request and receive made
and I'd be curious to see if it mirrors
what we know from International
jurisdictions everywhere where this data
is collected elsewhere we know that it
is the socially advantaged who are
accessing assisted dying not the
socially disadvantaged so I'll be
curious to see if that plays out in the
Canadian context which is what I expect
to be frank that said I think we do have
a good idea of how people describe their
own suffering and therefore why they are
requesting made primarily it's for
people who can no longer do the things
that bring meaning to their lives who no
longer are able to do what we call the
activities of daily living who've lost a
sense of dignity or Independence and I
think if we could find research that
would help us better understand what
leads to that type of suffering
potentially there's a way we can learn
to treat it
I'm concerned about this law having
I'll acknowledge the unintended but
profoundly disturbing consequence of
having people feel like they're a burden
and that they should choose death over
life that they should no longer demand
of their government of their fellow
citizens that care and support be
provided
in spent
individuals I can tell you that
Canadians are extremely grateful for
this option in a testament to the
quality of care being provided not a
single person has been charged with
misappropriate action I think Canada's
approach to assisted dying is more than
adequate it is solid it is good and for
some it may be a model for considering
care in their own region
[Music]
foreign